that's why a lot of people that ask me
that they want to be like entrepreneurs
and stuff on my honesty I don't think
it's that life is for most people or
maybe I'm just surrounded by losers but
that's true
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to another
great episode of careful boys we have
one of those two special guests we got
Patrick Riley over there
and we have men AKA what's a mortgage
with us what's a mortgage man
so we're already my mom's gonna be
watching this by the way oh your mom
watches
what that's so cool
I was telling her about it she's like
watch us like oh she likes she's like
okay I want to watch it let me know when
I like just kidding news and then I just
start off with a Vietnamese profanity
just great you did what'd you say I said
that's not a nice it's nice it's
delicious too so we know a little bit
about what you do you want to explain
for the viewers where your area of
expertise lies can I explain first okay
yeah yeah I like my explanations the
best okay because I have a different
experience so I'm always on my explore
page looking at [ __ ] and uh so you know
I fell in love with Chappelle because
just telling a lot of racist jokes so I
should probably shout out today yeah
that's what he's known for racist jokes
and then but man I was looking and then
one day he was like boohoo the interest
rates are going up you can't afford
anything and I was like this guy's
pretty funny
most like real estate or Finance
investor that kind of stuff it's like
some boring ass [ __ ] and why do they all
gotta look like they [ __ ] sell cheap
cars why you gotta talk about ad that
way bro
so that's what I found and then maybe
you can explain what you actually do
you can correct that it's a good good
setup all I do is do is he just makes
fun of people who can't afford a house I
was just telling when he came in I'm
like the way that he does it is very
different than most realtors that are
trying to like use social media to
advertise their businesses he packs a
ton of info and stuff that you want to
pause it you ever notice that a lot of
the time and I think like even though
you know I don't even know anything
about it I'm interested and I'm not even
you know in the home buying Market nice
but I feel like I am when I watch his
stuff which is nice you give us hope man
oh yeah thanks man so uh so yeah I mean
I do Residential Mortgage so I've been
doing mortgages since 2003 so I was in
school
and someone sent me an e-fax I don't
even remember e-facts back in the days
where it's like you just damn I'm old
now I remember
2003 when you fact something over but it
comes over as a PDF yeah and someone
showed me a check for like 40 something
thousand dollars like what the [ __ ] are
you doing like I'm gonna quit what I'm
doing and yeah so I dropped out of
school and I jumped in and got into
mortgages in 2000 what were you in
school for when you dropped out
um just taking General classes oh wow
like College college yeah I went to Cal
State Fullerton first didn't pan out
that well I went to FJ the junior
college oh damn Fullerton so homie just
[ __ ] try to rub it in your face look
at this 40G oh is that where you got
your Instagram idea from boom
were you in a car accident did you get
like a check from insurance like no it's
like it's from two mortgages so I
dropped out of school I quit I you know
let my vending machine business go and I
got the mortgages you had a vending
machine business yeah that sounds really
cool well you were serious as well yeah
yeah everyone's talking about doing that
[ __ ] like you used to stop machines
stock machines yeah I had my own
machines at a couple high schools had to
grease some principles but they were in
schools how much how much is the average
principal back then how do you buy it
well like 500 bucks you got to give them
like like you'll say for every someone
every time someone buys a drink I'll
give you a nickel or 10 cents it depends
on the shock collar is at the school
district or at the school that's quite
it and that was under the table green
yeah
that's how it works I had the I had the
hockey coach and he ran like the the
boys gym I mean the boys locker room so
I had machines in there so that's how I
made money back was it snacks and drinks
just drinks so if they don't bite into
is
something that has a hockey team I
wonder if they're not even they're
working there anymore oh they're not
working there anymore at all that's fine
I just say their name man
damn so you're what 20 something yeah 23
at that time doing all that [ __ ]
corrupt corrupt working with corrupt
officials at the high school and who
sent you a fact about vending machines
that made you want to do that no that I
just got into just sporadically and then
so then I got the mortgages and then of
course the crash happened of course I
retreated moved back home in 2008 but I
sat through the the market and you know
in 2008 feels like it is right now where
today this is like a cakewalk compared
to 2008 2008 people wanted to get homes
but there was no Bank letting out money
now banks are lending out money but no
one can afford the home so it's kind of
like vice versa so when you were when
you saw the crash in 2008 right
um You Were how old were you 28 and you
were you've been in the business like
real estate mortgage for like five years
already correct oh [ __ ] so it was a
humbling moving back home so did you get
like absolutely destroyed yes I got
absolutely destroyed so I moved back
home of course moving back home was the
best because can you paint a numerical
picture of what absolutely destroyed me
yeah how much I lost everything I mean
like everything like negative or zero
don't don't like because some of the
people in there lost Millions so what's
the what's your name oh no back in 2008
it was like a couple hundred thousand I
feel like after I spent could lost a
couple hundred thousand but a couple
hundred thousand under 30 years old is a
[ __ ]
but in 2017 uh I lost 1.7 million and I
no so I lost three million I and I owed
1.7 2017. and then I climbed my climbed
out of it to build things again so of
course the market bounced back I haha
you lost more than me
you lost it twice
how did you how did you climb out of it
uh when I when everyone got out of the
market I sat through it and I just
started doing my own business and then
um do my own originations or getting my
own loans again and then one by one I
was still spending money because I
started making money like every dumb ass
you know so I'm investing it and then
I'll start popping bottles everywhere
when doors open doves would fly so of
course whatever this guy's doing I want
to do it you bought a bunch of doves
and then of course everyone started more
and more my friends are coming back in
the industry so they all worked for me
so now I have this big old network of
loan officers oh wow so in 2015 I had
the bright idea you know you know I'm
gonna leave I left the the company I was
with and I had my own company and that's
when I started burning through all my
own money dude in 2014-15 there was a
season I was making like 600 Grand a
month just like
not doing [ __ ] all day and then this is
all from getting a month yeah for
getting loans you were just making wow
yeah I burnt and then
they deserve a dub or two yeah well this
is this is that new money stage where we
all experience if you get the pleasure
to experience you burn through all of it
you take you just PG you know PJ
everywhere PJ everywhere
oh you took private jobs I never even
got to that level bro I got jet sweet X
that's the most private I got uberX oh
you know what the most private I went to
was a Cessna because a student was like
I got I gotta I gotta learn how to fly
but you want to jump into playing with
me and I'm like yeah dude flyer yeah but
it's a private though dude private
student flyer yeah how bumpy was that
ride though how bumpy was it we had
turbulence
600 G's a month you know what what's
your lifestyle doves it's like I lived
in an apartment because I just was just
spending the money on stupid things and
just reinvesting reinvest some of it
spent it uh and because we had such a
huge team I kept on trying to inquire
more teams so I would like pay their
bills so they can come over leave their
companies so that's where most of the
money went and then in 2017 when we left
it's kind of got Jerry Maguire who's
with me and crickets like half the two
thirds of the team left a third stadium
with the company and then you know we
just I knew how to make it rain business
but I didn't know how to run a business
and you know we burned through all that
money and we lost a lot so about two
years my brother and I we lost
everything you know and then I had to
sell so in 2017 we started what's a
mortgage when I was losing everything
and literally we got down to our last
like 500 Grand and then even with the
500 Grand I gave my wife 250. I took the
250 I covered other bills because I put
the business under my brother's name I
wasn't going to take my let my brother
take the fall so I just use that to like
preserve and hold on to you know
whatever I could paid off a lot of bills
and then started rebuilding again
so so when you mentioned like you knew
how to do a business but not like run a
business that means like you were great
at sales but you couldn't run the
organization correct oh and what was the
reason for the Jerry Maguire moment
anyway where you had because yeah
everyone everyone I think every man or
every business person always thinks
their dick is bigger than it is yeah and
then you bite off more than then you
know you thought you're stepping on it
but you're really not you're stepping on
you know
that's my dick
[Laughter]
you gotta reset you know so so that's
why you think like you know I can do it
without this guy I got reserves I can
move on we already have our house like
let me keep let me you know let me push
forward and I did and in mortgages
because then she have to to make money
you're leveraging so much money at one
time it's like you have this Ferrari in
the parking lot you can't drive because
you have to hold it for collateral and
of course as Lone Star we had some bad
loans that they picked the Ferrari so
you gotta put up another Ferrari you
know sorry and then you you think
instead of like you know what time would
just uh wash our hands and walk away I
fought till the end like a dumbass with
my Autumn with my pride instead of you
know what let me cut my losses bled out
yeah let me let me cut my losses put my
tail between my legs and and re and
reset or like you know what I have
enough money I can chill out for a while
but I didn't I'm like you know what I'm
gonna beat this thing into submission
because if I've done it before I can do
it again and I fell flat on my face my
wife and I we sold our house she moved
uh into another city we were like on
Rocky Roads she's like you know what
figure out your life don't stress about
being a father and a husband until you
you get your [ __ ] together so even the
marriage is like yeah so I moved back on
my parents so it's my second time back
at my mom's house you know eating to
call again
be supportive of her yeah to be like yo
figure out like like I'll take care of
the kids and you just stay on your
hustle oh you only people [ __ ] on me
because she's way better looking than me
so like she was with you for your money
the whole time
you know but she met me when I drew my
like I caught my Silver Bullet my Honda
Accord she's like so she was with me
after that too so she no one knew like
she would stick around like she ain't
gonna stick around she gonna stick
around so I'm at my parents house living
there from
um after we sold our house March 2008 I
still owed uh 2018 I owed 1.7 million I
reversed that in one year what in
November all the debt was gone
you think only fans people can make
money so can short Asian guys
so you had a massage parlor too yeah so
so yeah I reverse it all and then what's
a head job you know but what's up pretty
much each one's a nickel dude it's a
mortgage and massage good business so uh
so after we reversed it all
um you know I was tired I signed this
big contract with U.S bank and then
things just got a little bit easier
things are comfortable now but you know
so when I talk to uh people who buy or
rent I have more empathy because I know
how it is to you know it's easy to say
oh buy home buy a home buy home like
these other Realtors and lenders but
it's hard to oh I'll tell you've been
making fun of them these days I make I
try to make light of the situation so
but yeah so now what does that mean that
you signed a deal with U.S bank so I
signed like a signing bonus with them
because I was um doing the the what's a
mortgage Channel
um I wiped out a lot of my debt with
with the page we don't make that type of
money now than we did
um we don't make that type of money now
that we did back then because I was
actually doing the loan but I'm so burnt
out like I'd rather make less money but
Pace myself and not kill myself you know
let me get out of this debt first but I
was giving a lot of business to this one
loan officer uh who was at U.S Bank the
deals we couldn't do and that's the cool
thing about my channel is that we only
do deals we
can do the ones we can we just don't go
here how many times I told you like go
here instead go here instead and people
like that which made me feel like oh man
like men's so authentic because it's
like a lot of people try to keep
business to himself and he was like oh
you know what that loan you're looking
for I don't even offer it but you'll
like hook me up with someone else I'm
like oh that's so cool so we were giving
these deals to US bank and then they're
like hey you're getting so many deals
let us take some of your costs off
um off of you and also why don't you
join us and here's like 250 Grand sign
and join us so we did a six-month
contract with them and then
you know I went to loan Depot after that
and then pretty much things just kept
going so loan Depot yeah for season
first season before they went public
then when they went public I think I
still yeah I can talk about now because
I know they had like uh I couldn't talk
about it up until I think may this year
so so we were with them for a while they
went public and then things just changed
and then we went independent and now
we're selling pretty much providing our
viewership selling it to another lender
and then we're also starting to close a
lot of our own business now damn so
after all the stuff I learned just like
pace yourself and you know
calculated moves you sound crazy and
don't step on your dick it ain't that
big as you think it is but to be honest
though like almost every entrepreneur I
know has this story of I [ __ ] almost
lost everything and then I did it again
it almost feels like it's like you have
to I well at least for me I don't know
any story of someone who's started
something and then like they've been
perfectly like on the right track all
the way without [ __ ] up you know like
I think personality wise entrepreneurs
are stubborn and then they just [ __ ]
beat the [ __ ] out of something and see
what their limits are and sometimes
those limits are like it'll kill you but
then like you know what I mean right
like they just keep going and going and
going and then they have to figure out
what their burnout threshold all that
and then they go maybe I should like
chill out a little bit Yeah because I
really don't know anyone yeah yeah
and then later we all feel like maybe we
shouldn't have spent so much on the
business maybe I should have saved like
a little a bit you know but that's why a
lot of people that ask me that they want
to be like entrepreneurs and stuff on my
honesty I don't think it's that life is
for most people I don't think so either
[ __ ] if it's like if you like if you
want your like uber ride to be a roller
coaster every [ __ ] day yeah then go
ahead but so most people want a nice
smooth Uber ride you know or maybe I'm
just surrounded by losers but
[Laughter]
that's true
so like what you went through in 2008
with that crash versus what someone like
you might be going through in this crash
what's the difference really
I think a lot of people uh aren't a lot
of loan officers or Realtors aren't
doing they're not taking a pay cut
even right now I took a pay cut because
I need to pump more money to ads you got
to see this face everywhere to make
money as soon as we get out of this and
everyone's like oh they just trying to
take everything they can because they
don't know when the next dollar is
coming in move Home Live modest if you
can't move home go to the place with
cheaper rent people just don't want to
step down or take a pay uh decrease you
know when things aren't good like I said
I could have just walked away I probably
wouldn't work right now if I would have
walked away in 2016. when I had a chance
to I had so money in the bank like no
I'm gonna fight through this I'm gonna
fight this instead of taking you know
what let me cool my lifestyle dude I was
going out spending like a thousand bucks
a week on dumb stuff when things weren't
good I'm like you know what I'm gonna
I'm gonna eventually make it again why
why slow down why slow down you know so
for you it was like you could have been
more conservative correct like stop
spending on white doves flying
everywhere
other places like you don't have you
don't make watermelon juice here's some
money go get a blender and bring in some
watermelon
and blend me some watermelon juice so I
can drink it with my vodka wouldn't that
take long because they have to run to
the Ralphs and get a blender yeah it's
supposed to be able to do it the feeling
though the time that you get is the fact
that you made somebody do it when they
didn't have a blender but you have to
wait at the restaurant for five hours so
they could buy it at the Ralph's if
there's already five strippers sucking
your dick at the restaurant you got
plenty of time in 30 seconds and then I
get tired
oh and then you get a sleeping bag and
then you take a nap at the restaurant
and you wake up the reason why we gotta
get it like dude they have a blender
there well because of the safety codes
they can't bring their their uh their uh
what's called Big industrial blender out
so to bring a small Blender at the table
because my buddy wanted fresh watermelon
dude it was crazy times
just for fun can you tell us some other
frivolous things you've spent that you
wish you could get the money back from
so there was one night I got the I got
the back call from these uh Middle
Eastern guys and they're like let's go
hang out let's go to Vegas
and it wasn't it was just on a Tuesday
and I'm like okay you know like I'll
bring some money with me I'll bring like
10 000 bucks we'll probably spend a day
or two I saw the bill and it was over a
hundred grand and I'm like sitting like
I get that 10 grand was just like on top
of another 10 grand so we were all like
what kind of bill was it yeah at
excessive just at a club
for one night so you guys you guys party
yeah
and spent 100 Grand is it because the
table was it the table I don't know I
think I think that's when like Afrojack
was big I forgot when it was like there
was some big DJ and it was like he just
air dropped in and it was a big old
thing and you know yeah and then the
table rates go crazy yeah you had to pay
for his airdrop so the table rate could
have been like 50 Grand by itself and
then all the bottles yeah well the 50
gram would come with like the minimum
and then yeah and then of course there's
like uh and at one time I bought I
bought a bottle of uh or a champagne
bottles like 19 Grand I was like are you
kidding me like why did I do this you
know oh yeah trust me though those
things are like dude where can I get
invested where like I think about that
now now Mike is Frugal as hell what is
it like drinking at 19 because I would
imagine like you you want to savor it so
[ __ ] much that you can't enjoy it you
know what I mean you like every sip it's
like that was four thousand dollars just
like this
[Laughter]
it was crazy that night that bottle of
champagne didn't taste that good it
wasn't 19 000. what does it feel like
does it feel like you're skydiving you
know like when you're because I think
when you're drinking champagne
and you're when you're doing baller [ __ ]
the reason why you do them is the thrill
is insane right so like let's say like
well like for like Joe for example 5000
on black that feeling you're like oh my
[ __ ] god so it's like skydiving just
doing that at the table oh [ __ ] right
but that's why you do baller [ __ ] right
where you're like as you drink this
champagne oh yeah you're like you know
what this Ferrari [ __ ] this car watch
this and you just crashed into the
building I don't give a [ __ ] right so
when it's like 19 000 champagne does it
feel like you're drinking your [ __ ]
skydiving or something I think the
moment but then afterwards when the
music turns down you're like oh my God
you're sitting the room like literally
like like the guilt after you bust a nut
yeah
that post nuts for a second uh feels
crazy in that second I think another
crazy time was that we were in uh I
think we were in Seattle uh the Seahawks
were playing and we went out and my
buddies like they do dispensaries so
they have like cash cash they gotta like
throw out so we had a table next to uh I
think it was like Richard Sherman he was
throwing ones they were throwing ones he
was throwing fives they were throwing
fives and tens I'm like Oh my God
in the air throwing fives throwing out
in the air fives just throwing fives in
there and I'm like dude I'll never do
this again like so as I'm doing it like
regretting it but like so most of the
things you spent were like lifestyle
events and not so much like items right
correct correct well we like I had a
couple watches like I bought I ended up
you know selling it was like I'll never
buy an expensive watch again it doesn't
make you [ __ ] longer it doesn't make
your dick bigger it doesn't make you
skinnier unless it does all three of
those things I'm not paying for it
Apple's working on that I'll have all my
Rolexes um I bought and I sold it used
for what I bought it for so one I had I
bought it I sold it for 100 bucks more
so I felt like I got a free watch 100
bucks more it's nice yeah it was a
datejust I sold it back used for 100
bucks more to a jewelry shop oh yeah
that's very rare that is rare it's
pretty good they get collectible right
yeah they go up in Valley it went up in
value just recently like during the
lockdown so I got lucky and I was like
oh baby I got I got to wear a free
[ __ ] watch that I didn't I didn't do
nothing and a hundred thousand more
steps like that and you make your crypto
money back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]